[Aplausos]
estamos prontos para o court
muitos de vocês estão familiarizados com
a expulsão do sul
aquilo como esperar provavelmente até
concordam com essa opção pois eu não
e para explicar por que eu coloco na
minha vocês aqui agora duas perguntas
relativamente simples de manhã após
acordar como que um dos locais para este
evento terex hora lembra um clipe carro
deslocaram para sair também pro vários
outros carros e próxima pergunta é
quantos carros exatamente é que ouve a
mensagem 500 antes em uma base diária
estamos dispostos um sem-número de
informação estimou
e essa informação vai passar por um
processo de seleção em que o cérebro
escolhe o que vai ter e até mesmo em que
vai pensar não fiz essa informação e
talita que nós não conseguimos ser
indivíduos muito funcionais ou se quer
ter uma vida normal
curiosamente a nossa gestão não funciona
de forma muito franca
todos os alimentos líquidos e sólidos
que o engenheiro distintivo selecionar
alguns pratos e outros preliminar
portanto alguns alimentos vão passar a
fazer parte de mim outros não mas esta
questão ganha outra dimensão quando eu
incluo nela tudo meu mundo interno
emocional afirma ascensões as sensações
por uma base diária o cinto e as coisas
tão exposta que vão passar também elas
por um processo mais com cento menos
consciente seleção em que eu por exemplo
escolheu sentir entusiasmo em vez de
ansiedade ou empenho em vez de empatia
tanto de coisas
a questão é que eu faço com elas
no atual momento eu sou aquilo que
dirigir ou é que eu faço do como e isso
também a forma como eu vos lhe as minhas
intenções aqui um paralelismo fascinante
entre o meu processamento intelectual a
minha gestão física e metabolismo
emocional
tudo bem mas agora vocês dizem
catarinense é tudo muito bonito mas
porque aqui se interessa
bom todos os crimes em que vai querer
ter boa saúde e bem-estar versão e bem
estar não só acerca do tema das
respostas certas
acima de tudo um dom são a ser que
fazemos perguntas mais interessantes que
perguntas cabem espaço há mais hipóteses
mais possibilidades tem na nossa saúde
em fight mais jogadores mais
consistentes mais sustentáveis que eles
fazem que se por dentro quando eu invés
de tentar obter uma resposta rápida e
compartimentalizar eu sinto uma absurda
o meu comportamento alimentar uma
caixinha com níveis de sempre questiono
o que eu estou a ter este comportamento
que estou a desenvolver sintomas
capturar descobrir três elementos que
não só podem melhorar
fundamentalmente a minha saúde mas a
minha relação comigo ea minha relação
com a vida
ora como é que eu sei isto como é que eu
fui barrar com estes três aumentos não
foi só porque usa teorizar em estudar
sinte utilizar isto dói ficar mas a
verdade é que no que diz respeito à
alimentação
a minha maior vitória tem sido a minha
vida porque eu fiz tudo errado tudo
durante 10 anos tive uma dependência do
álcool
foram dez anos em que a bebida pra minha
curso a vaca trauma e minha incapacidade
de ver as minhas intenções durante quase
20 anos tive de ordem alimentar de uma
bulimia esfera em que pra mim o purgar
alimentos funcionava como um substituto
simbólico prometeu tentar esperado
tentar eliminar impressões emoções que
eu considerava exportáveis para expurgar
criar um vazio que eu não sou não só no
estômago mas acima de tudo um vazio no
coração que voltava a tentar preencher
com mais comida e aqui o que eu aprender
foi que o corpo é profundamente
simbólico
tanto os seus sintomas como os seus
comportamentos também desenvolver os
sintomas a minha cara estava
frequentemente coberta em aqui
desenvolveu a síndrome do cólon
irritável ponto que me perseguem chava
tal maneira que buscavam a perguntar se
eu estava grávida passei por uma
depressão profunda e quando cheguei aos
meus 20 anos tinha lapsos esportes mori
e muito atribulado em concentração
portanto eu sei o que é estar das lavras
eu conheço bem o sentimento de
impotência e desespero dentro tem que
ser quase total quase e essa é a palavra
chave
bem feitas as contas o poder de mudança
está nas minhas mãos e foi o conhecer
dessa responsabilidade
ele permitiu finalmente parar com as
três aumentos do primário ao tom e
identificação imaginar todos os dias
após um longo dia de trabalho chega à
casa cansada xerfan foi jantar aquecer
nos favorece a visão após terminar ele
mesmo mesmo apoiando apesar de ter feito
uma refeição completa
a lei 3 contínuo que o buraco no
estômago
então eles macaquinha abre o armário
ainda tenho as minhas posições favoritas
como docente quatro só comer uma ou duas
pessoas passam quatro que eu coloco meu
limite
eventualmente retirar a próxima copa
estava sem treinar
vai dormir melhor tempo com 23
ninguém aqui nessa história né quando
estive não só aumentar o buraco no
estômago mas um sentimento profundo
culpa as fraquezas fraca força de
vontade e esse sentimento passam a fazer
parte da minha identidade é para mudar
os maus comportamentos e eu tenha que
mudar o meu sentido de identidade e
desvincular o meu autoconceito das
minhas ações e de forma como sem
internação elas ou seja eu posso sentir
culpada
eu posso sentir frustrada e possa
desenvolver sentimentos do falhanço de
fraqueza mas eu não sou culpa eu não sou
a frustração eu não sou eu sou
responsável pelas minhas ações sem
autonomia delas e foi criar esse espaço
de autonomia que permitiu finalmente não
só as minhas crenças mas acima de tudo
mudar os maus comportamentos e por
muitas abordagens elaboradas que eu
tentasse tentar e foram 20 anos
a resposta final era tão simples não faz
os cintos eu tinha que mudar o meu
sentido eo segundo momento os meus avós
eram frequentemente passados não só pé
mas a caminhar enquanto julgamento ponto
a e b do meu trabalho para atualmente a
rapidez com que o crime era tal que nem
dava conta que estava a investigar mas
mesma noite já em casa supostamente
achava a rapidez com que eu tinha vivido
meu dia acaba traduzir na rapidez com
que eu comia por esta multiplicidade
constante tirava a minha refeição
qualquer sentido prazer que eu não sabia
na altura era que o corinthians ia
porque aí não tem jeito é que distam é
composta por quatro fácil e essa
primeira dessas faz é chamada das faça
falei que é da gestão que outra forma de
dizer a fase disse brown da gestão sã e
essa fase diz respeito quase
exclusivamente a minha experiência da
refeição
portanto estamos a referir ao antecipar
da refeição ao aroma dos alimentos ao
visual a aparência dos alimentos é todo
o contexto em que está inserida ao
desfrutar da refeição portanto parem
eu não estou aqui falando que me dá eu
estou aqui falar bem os sonhos estão
essas opções que vão estimular o sistema
nervoso central que vai pôr se dar
início à produção de enzimas digestivas
inclusive prince estimam que cerca de
40% já ouvi dizer sentar-nos pronto
vamos ficar correndo
mesmo assim o número vá do nosso poder
desse tipo vêm exclusivamente esta faça
falei que isso quer dizer
quando eu estou é retirar esta parte do
meu viver da refeição eu estou a reduzir
dramaticamente o meu objetivo
qual é a relevância deste trabalho
resultados
do tipo de funções digestivas e chassi
dor abdominal flatulência azia por aí
fora
escreva mais importante do que isso é
que eu fique com uma espuma e portanto
com mais não só pra compensar é
deficiência nutritiva nutrientes que não
assimila indevidamente mas também com a
ausência de prazer componente necessária
a fábrica portanto ficou mais forte com
mais ganham mais peso por isso é quando
nós estamos a tentar suprimir um sintoma
província forçosamente sem ver o
panorama maior nos fighter pela culatra
e por isso também é que grande maioria
das estatísticas ea ea e números
estatísticas dizem que a maioria das
dietas a longo prazo
falham por a solução para este problema
curiosa porque parece ser assim como
parceiros como não é necessariamente
prática comum é necessário para nós
eu também saí do carlos o nosso rito
interno de felinos não só a nossa
relação com a comida mas a nossa relação
com a vida
vou continuar a comer e viver sempre em
constante você dá andar conta daquilo
que estou a comer ea viver eu vou
escolher fazer com mais presença e isso
leva ao terceiro aumento é minha forma
de comércio é um espelho da minha forma
de viver
amei a anual trata de uma série de
workshops porque desde há uns quatro
anos que nadava desenvolver todo tipo de
funções digestivas episódio já tenha
alterado a sua dieta e ter feito um sem
número de intervenções sem sucesso
nunca tinham perguntado concurso cidade
aquela comida
entretanto que o conselho não sabem é
que maria estava sempre preocupada
sempre ter pressa
ela maria movimentava as compressas com
dia com pressa por visivelmente incluia
compressas não porque não quisesse
exportar da refeição mas porque sua
atitude vida reitera que não tinha tempo
para nada
após cerca de dois meses da educação do
seu regime interno sentido de
desacelerar a maioria segundo as suas
palavras têm melhorado 80% dos seus
problemas e voltar a dirigir e melhor
tinha perdido mais de três quilos
a mensagem é que é mudar o meu corpo
minha dieta saúde não é só a cerca é
acerca de viver de franco acerca de como
eu vim pra mesa que me aborda a minha
refeição desde a escolha dos alimentos
até a forma como eu sugiro é acerca da
minha relação com a comida
comigo com meu corpo com os outros é
acerca da forma como eu vou gerir o
stress e outras emoções mais difíceis do
como confortável estou com meu próprio
de conforto e do impacto que todos esses
parâmetros vão ter na minha saúde
na minha escolha de alimentos e os meus
comportamentos alimentares porque
lembrança
o corpo é profundamente simbólico tanto
nos seus sintomas como os seus
comportamentos
vou continuar por exemplo em sears o
buraco simples estômago ou por saber que
aquilo que eu tenho realmente preencer
eu vazio que tem no coração vazio porque
sinto falta de intimidade da minha vida
de verdade falta de propósito
vou continuar em guerra com comida que
meu corpo não gosto das ancas da barriga
das coisas do nariz alvo tratar os meus
elementos que o mesmo tem qualidade e
respeito acrílico
portanto estes três elementos
transformar meu sentimento de identidade
a reeducar o regime interno e percebeu o
paralelismo entre a minha relação com a
comida ea minha relação com a comida
convida transformaram assim como tem
transformado as pessoas com quem eu
trabalho fizeram nos perceber que afinal
então é isso que se quer mudar qualquer
coisa no meu corpo e da minha saúde
eu tenho também cuidar a minha atitude
mais comportamentos porque será
será mesmo por dentro não tem como a
prescrição tem como a transformação do
meu caráter e na minha vida obrigada
[Aplausos]